Trascrizione: Lorella Mejdani
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Da sempre, l'umanità si è mossa
con l'intenzione di superare i confini,
di superare i propri limiti.
Questo irrefrenabile desiderio
di andare oltre, di scoprire,
di sfidare, di sfidarsi.
E già da piccoli ci si sente
un po' esploratori:
vogliosi di andare, di scoprire.
E quando hai tre anni,
e riesci a superare di 30 metri
gli occhi vigili di mamma e di papà,
ti sembra di aver fatto un'impresa.
Man mano poi i confini dilatano,
la voglia di andare oltre
aumenta in modo esponenziale.
Be', non c'è nulla da fare:
la storia lo insegna,
e il nostro DNA ce lo dice;
siamo fatti per andare alla scoperta.
Esplorare.
Quando tutto accadde,
non sentivo in me il desiderio
di superare i miei, di limiti;
ma semplicemente avevo il desiderio
di sentirmi viva, appagata, realizzata.
E così ho scoperto quanto fosse bello
assaporare nuovi mondi, esplorare,
godere di nuove esperienze.
E perché non farlo di corsa?
Io sono un ultra maratoneta,
ve l'hanno detto, amo correre;
e perché non portare con me
questa mia passione
in questa incantevole avventura?
E così, insieme alla mia amica corsa,
con uno zainetto sulle spalle
ho attraversato i più grandi
deserti del mondo,
ho girato in lungo e in largo continenti.
Spingendomi ogni volta
sempre un po' oltre,
ma a volte senza nemmeno saperlo.
E ogni volta trovavo
una nuova sensazione da assaporare.
Capii che andare oltre, in fondo,
cavolo, era piacevole.
Ogni volta mi si apriva
un mondo ricco di emozioni.
Compresi che, in sostanza,
i confini non sono
che i limiti prestabiliti;
e che non sempre determinano
una verità, un sapere, un qualcosa.
E proprio in uno
di questi miei sconfinamenti
ho trovato la risposta
a questa mia ricerca,
un senso che ha dato un nuovo valore
e significato a questo mio percorso,
e che ora sono qui a condividere con voi.
Un po' di anni fa trovai,
in mezzo ai miei ricordi,
un foglietto che avevo
disegnato a 14 anni:
c'era una semplice duna
con un rametto, mosso dal vento,
e sopra c'era scritto
"Vorrei sentire il rumore
del silenzio nel deserto".
Ricordo che mi era sempre piaciuta l'idea
di poter andare in un luogo
isolato, immenso,
dove ti senti piccolo,
dove l'uomo non è il protagonista supremo.
E assaporare questa immensità,
e il suo silenzio.
In effetti non avevo tutti i torti,
perché adesso che ho corso
in tantissimi deserti del mondo
devo dire che correre in un deserto
è una delle cose più belle della vita.
Prima di tutto, è necessaria
una cosa: l'umiltà.
Non si può pensare
di andare lì e di sfidarlo,
perché sennò te la fa pagare.
Non puoi pensare di fregarlo.
E tutte le persone
che ho visto personalmente
che hanno avuto questo approccio,
l'hanno pagata cara:
con colpi di calore, colpi di sole...
Io chiedo sempre il permesso
di passare, dentro di me:
non lo dico a nessuno,
è come una preghiera.
Chiedo il permesso al deserto,
il permesso di passare.
La vedo un po' come una forma di rispetto.
E se lo tratti bene,
il deserto, e lo ammiri,
lui ti regala delle esperienze
che arricchiranno per sempre la tua vita.
Mi è capitato di correre
con zebre e antilopi in Namibia;
ho visto stellate meravigliose;
ho ascoltato il suono della sabbia
fischiettare sotto i miei piedi,
perché in alcune condizioni metereologiche
la sabbia fischietta al tuo passaggio.
E poi ho corso giù dalle dune.
Si torna ad essere bambini,
correndo giù dalle dune.
Ho avuto un sacco di pensieri,
un sacco di miraggi.
E poi, poi ho capito.
Ho capito una cosa.
Ho capito quanto sia importante la vita.
Ho capito quanto a volte pensiamo
di necessitare di cose,
ma che alla fine valgono zero.
Quando si vive una settimana
in autosufficienza,
portando tutto quello che serve
sulle proprie spalle,
si capisce davvero cosa sia
davvero importante e cosa no.
Si capisce quanto un cellulare
sia utile, ma spesso inutile.
Il cellulare non si porta spesso,
ma sapete perché?
Perché nel deserto, spesso,
non c'è campo, non c'è connessione.
E se anche ce n'è, io me ne frego,
lui se ne frega della connessione.
Perché non abbiamo bisogno
di Facebook, Instagram, Internet.
Non c'è bisogno di nulla.
Perché?
Perché quando sei lì,
hai voglia di essere lì e basta.
Lì in quel qui e ora.
Allora si scoprono quelle cose semplici,
ma che avevamo dimenticato
perché inquinati dall'inutile.
La bellezza di parlare con delle persone
senza essere interrotti da una suoneria;
la bellezza di assaporare un brodino caldo
prima che arrivi il freddo
della notte nel deserto.
Oppure, semplicemente, assaporare
l'ultimo pezzo di parmigiano reggiano
che ti tenevi lì nello zainetto,
condividerlo con un coreano
che in cambio lui ti regala -
magari - dei gamberetti secchi.
Gamberetti secchi mangiati
a colazione - ve lo auguro a tutti.
Comunque, qui, in questa situazione,
in questi momenti, qual è il confine?
Ma qui esistono dei limiti?
Dei blocchi?
È un accettare il mondo così com'è.
È assaporare un momento
e non dimenticarlo più.
E il tempo così rallenta,
cioè si riprende - o meglio -
i propri spazi, i propri preziosi secondi,
facendoceli rivivere tutti
con estrema pienezza.
Ecco: tutto ebbe inizio
in questa situazione.
E più precisamente in Africa.
E ancora più precisamente nel Mali,
lungo la falesia di Bandiagara.
Era una gara che attraversava
tutti i paesi del Dogon,
una tribù meravigliosa
che racchiude una storia e delle usanze,
un misticismo, incredibili.
Ero in mezzo a una natura arida,
dove il silenzio aveva
una voce avvolgente,
quel torpore mattutino e tiepido
che solo l'Africa ti sa donare:
un'Africa di baobab parlanti,
dalla terra dei tramonti rosso fuoco.
Un'Africa di zolle di sabbia polverosa,
del caldo che ti avvolge,
quell'Africa dalle migliaia di stelle
che ti fanno da coperta la notte.
Con quegli odori di spezie
che ti perforano il naso
e non le dimentichi più.
L'Africa, anche, di visi e sguardi,
che ti guardano un po' guardinghi,
con attenzione, un po' diffidenti eh.
Però poi, alla fine,
ti regalano sempre un sorriso,
o almeno un cenno di saluto.
In quel luogo mistico,
ho trovato delle risposte
che forse cercavo anche da tempo.
Ecco, ora immaginate una donna
come me - anzi, me.
Una donna caucasica
alta un metro e un'aspirina,
e con delle borracce addosso,
e che corre in mezzo
al nulla, in un deserto.
E io spesso venivo scambiata per un uomo,
con queste calze di compressione.
Le donne - potete immaginare -
non usano correre.
Non usano correre,
e comunque usano vestire
con foulard colorati.
Insomma, una donna
si riconosce a distanza;
e io venivo riconosciuta a pochi metri,
quando mi vedevano in faccia.
Ricordo, in particolar modo,
un mio ingresso
in uno di questi mille paesi attraversati.
Avevo alcuni tifosi
che mi accoglievano con applausi.
Poco più in là vidi un bimbo,
avrà avuto due o tre anni:
era completamente nudo.
E al mio passaggio iniziò a piangere
e scappare per i campi,
come se avesse visto un mostro.
Ero io. Ero io il mostro.
Infatti feci un sorriso,
accettando a malincuore di essere
l'orco cattivo della sua giornata.
Abbassai lo sguardo e continuai a correre.
E poco più avanti
vidi due donne, le sorpassai
e sentii che una diceva all'altra
"Est une madame! Est une madame!"
usando il francese, non la loro lingua,
quasi come se volesse
che io capissi cosa stava dicendo.
Allora mi fermai, mi girai,
le feci un sorriso felice.
E lei contraccambiò
con uno sguardo di occhi dolci,
lucidi, profondi, meravigliosi.
Ecco: in quel momento,
io sentii una connessione,
un forte legame con quella donna
di cui non sapevo assolutamente nulla.
Non sapevo se era sposata,
non sapevo l'età,
non sapevo proprio della sua esistenza
fino a due secondi prima.
Però in quel momento
ricordo di aver fatto un pensiero
in merito a questa energia,
a questa empatia avvertita:
eravamo entrambe donne.
Uguali.
E sicuramente, anche se appartenenti
a due culture completamente diverse,
avevamo qualcosa in comune.
Ecco, io ebbi la sensazione
che questo nostro essere donne
non aveva confini di cultura, religione.
Era una comune appartenenza.
Un essere uguali.
Così mi resi conto
che troppo spesso ci poniamo dei limiti
sia fisici che mentali,
limitando territori, persone, generi;
e, a volte, anche pensieri.
Creando così una gabbia, intorno a noi,
dove mente e corpo rimangono confinati
in idee, opinioni, culture, usanze.
A volte queste sono meravigliose,
perché denotano preziose tradizioni,
legami alla propria terra, cultura.
Però altre volte sono motivo
di inutili lotte e violenze.
E una di queste,
forse la più barbara e inutile,
è la violenza sulla donna.
E questo limite, questa cosa,
ha sconfinato. Non è rimasta lì.
Una donna su tre al mondo,
secondo il Ministero della Salute,
è stata violentata, picchiata,
costretta all'atto sessuale,
oppure abusata,
almeno una volta nella sua vita.
Allora io, dopo aver scoperto questo dato,
tornai da questo viaggio.
E mi dissi:
"Ma chissà quante donne
ho incontrato io nella mia vita,
su un autobus, in un bar, al cinema,
quante donne ho sfiorato senza sapere
che si portavano un mostro dentro?"
Dati incredibili. Tristi.
E questo, ora, in tutto il mondo.
Non nei paesi poco sviluppati,
lontano da noi -
era in tutto il mondo, capite? Ovunque!
Allora ho deciso di portare un messaggio,
proprio in questo sconfinamento,
attraversando tutto il mondo,
dimostrando che se si vuole
è possibile superare
qualsiasi situazione ostile,
qualsiasi ostacolo che la vita
ci può mettere davanti.
È spesso solo la mente
che crea dei limiti,
che ci convince che non si può uscire
da alcuni schemi malati.
Ho deciso di dare vita
a un nuovo progetto:
era il 2010, "Run for Women".
Dove per la prima volta ho deciso
di agire con un fine -
permettetemi il gioco di parole -
con un fine preciso:
mettere al servizio
il mio impegno, la mia passione,
per qualcosa di più grande.
Un messaggio universale
che potesse arrivare a tutti,
e dare un senso al mio correre,
alla mia ricerca,
sperando così di migliorare la situazione
e superando qualsiasi confine.
Avrei attraversato in meno di un anno
i deserti di cinque continenti,
uno per ogni lettera
che componeva la parola "women";
e ogni volta che riuscivo
in questo intento,
la lettera si sarebbe illuminata.
Beh, ovviamente non potevo pensare
di risolvere tutto il problema del mondo;
però di farne luce sì.
Perché se qualcosa non è visibile,
noi non lo vediamo.
E se non lo vediamo,
non possiamo interagirci.
Era necessario almeno provare
ad accendere i riflettori
e dimostrare che, se si vuole,
tutto è possibile.
E ho così corso questi mille chilometri,
in cinque continenti,
usando le lettere "women",
"w", "o", "m", "e", "n".
E accendendo il mondo,
cercando di svegliarlo da questo coma,
di farlo reagire.
A volte si pensa che alcune cose
non siano possibili,
e io intendevo dimostrare
che se io riuscivo a correre
per centinaia di chilometri
a 40 gradi, sotto il Sole,
anche tu, donna violata, puoi uscire
da questo maledetto tunnel nero.
Infatti il mio messaggio
non era dedicato agli uomini:
"Ah, non fate male alle donne".
No, era dedicato alle donne,
a prendere in mano la propria vita,
a magari chiedere un aiuto a reagire.
Ecco: il progetto fu apprezzato
da molte testate giornalistiche;
una in particolare era "Runner's World",
che era una testata di settore.
Ebbene, una copia di quella rivista
fu gettata o persa,
non si sa, da qualcuno,
comunque cadde su un marciapiede milanese.
E cadde a pancia in su,
e si aprì proprio sul mio articolo.
E una donna stava passando da lì.
Era una giornata, anzi un periodo
proprio triste per questa donna:
lei aveva addirittura pensato
di farla finita proprio quella mattina lì.
Il destino volle che donna
e rivista si incontrarono;
lo sguardo della donna,
inizialmente arrabbiata,
perché qualcuno aveva buttato giù
per terra quella rivista,
si posò su quell'articolo.
Ecco: "Run for Women" fece ritrovare
un pochino di autostima a quella donna.
E fu per lei un piccolo trampolino,
un piccolo trampolino di inizio
per riprendere in mano la sua vita
e capire che alla fine era lei
la protagonista della sua vita,
e come tale poteva cambiarne il copione.
Ecco, questa donna si chiama Lina:
mi contattò, mi raccontò questa storia
e tuttora ci sentiamo,
mi fa spesso gli auguri
di Natale, di compleanno,
e mi ricorda il dono che le ho fatto.
Ora, io non so se ci sono altre donne -
io me lo auguro, ma non lo so -
a cui ho cambiato la vita.
So però con certezza
che una l'ho cambiata.
E solo per questo ne è valsa la pena.
La storia di Lina, e di tante altre amiche
che ci si sono unite con me
in questo messaggio,
in questa forza che ci unisce
non solo come donne ma come esseri umani,
mi fa credere e sperare con forza
che uniti per uno stesso ideale
sia possibile superare alcuni confini,
e che sia possibile lottare
per quello in cui si crede.
Per il nostro bene,
per qualcosa di giusto:
qualcosa che abbracci tutti noi,
tutti noi insieme, tutte e tutti noi.
Per questo corro: per le donne;
per le bambine che diventeranno donne;
per quelle che non sono ancora nate,
ma che nasceranno e saranno donne.
E continuerò a farlo:
sempre con il mio zainetto,
la mia dignità, la mia semplicità;
ma anche un po' di forza.
E lotterò per ogni cosa che credo
giusta e necessaria a questo mondo.
Ognuno di noi può fare la differenza.
Ognuno di noi può essere un esempio
per sé stesso e per gli altri.
L'importante è agire,
anche se con dei piccoli gesti.
Perché un piccolo gesto,
se moltiplicato per milioni di gesti,
diventa enorme.
E tutto è possibile, se si vuole farlo.
A volte si mettono dei confini
perché si ha solo paura di guardare oltre.
Ma sappiate che senza la paura
si corre più leggeri.
Grazie.
(Applausi)